what is going on with the 24 core m1 max
macbooks well i have some good news for
you guys and some bad news because today
we're going to talk about the full
performance of these machines both in
some benchmarks and 3d rendering also
video editing and gaming and get into
the mystery of the 24 core ever since
apple announced the m1 pro and m1 max
macbooks and we went on their website
and saw that there was one configuration
on there that they playing out did not
mention everybody had this question is
the 24 core m1 max chip the actual sweet
spot compared to the 16 core and the 32
core especially on the 14 inch macbook
pro if you're already getting 32 gigs of
ram which a lot of people are it is only
a 200 upgrade over the 16 core and it
has a ton of extra benefits if you go
for that which we'll talk about in just
a bit and when we started ordering our
macbooks which we ordered a ton of them
this was probably the one that i was
most excited about testing out because
it is like the unicorn in all of the
different configurations with these
macbooks you can't get it as a base
system if you upgrade to a more
expensive option you just straight up
jump to the 32 core but we made sure to
order one and right when i logged online
it already was backdated meaning you
couldn't get it on day one and here we
are over a month later so why is there
barely any coverage of this 24 core
machine that from what i know now is
probably the best m1 max chip to buy if
you care about bank for the buck which i
will get into now initially when i
ordered mine right away i got a date of
somewhere between the 5th and the 10th
which was quite a ways out there
compared to everything else coming in
right away then i got excited because it
changed to friday just three days after
the launch date but it didn't show up it
got kicked back to november 4th i was
like all right not too bad well back to
the original date and then when that
time came around it got kicked back
again to november 11th and here we are
what is it december 1st and guess what
apple still hasn't gotten me this
macbook and judging on videos and
articles it is nowhere really to be seen
now a few people online have posted
videos if you do a search like created
tech we have luke miyani couple other
smaller channels with very few tests and
there's pretty much nothing as far as
articles either but as you know we
bought a ton of different macbooks i
bought eight vadim deanbot one so we've
done a ton of testing and you guys have
been commenting below asking when are
you guys gonna make these videos on the
24 core this is the one i want to buy
well what i ended up doing is looking at
luke's videos create a text which we'll
put down in the video description
also notebook check for a couple things
and also retesting our machines and
running their tests with the exact same
settings they did to give you the most
comprehensive coverage of this machine
in doing so i found some things that
were really surprising to me with bigger
differences or not differences that i
expected in a positive way now there's
also a downside about this machine as
well so let's go ahead and jump into it
and i think that these tests are really
going to provide some clear info for you
now if apple ever gets this machine to
me um then we'll actually do some more
testing because online the stuff that i
found there was nothing very clear
about performance wattage frequencies
thermal throttling none of that stuff
other than some benchmarks but based on
these numbers i think you guys will be
quite surprised now starting off with
geekbench 5 we see this whole range of
macbooks right here and it looks like
the 24 core is right there somewhere in
the middle between the 16 and the 32
core now you guys may know that these
macbooks finish these tasks so quick
that the chips actually don't reach
their full potential because they kind
of ramp up in performance to save
battery life for super quick tests which
is a good thing but they don't max out
in geekbench 5. so that's where we're
going to take a look at gfx bench's
aztec runes which is a longer test it's
off screen so we don't have any
limitations um for the pro motion 120
hertz so i used this specific test i
ignored other results that didn't line
up if we look at the 16 core m1 pro and
then look at the 32 core results from
luke miani you see a noticeable
performance difference and then the 24
core is somewhere right there in the
middle once again right
well that's not exactly true now luke
tested a 16 inch for the 32 core and a
14 inch for the 24 core and the 32
performs won the 16 inch but what we
found in our detailed testing is that if
you're buying a 32 core in a 14 inch you
can get up to 36 percent less
performance and that is because one
thing that nobody else has mentioned is
that the m1 max 32 core in the 14 inch
macbook it actually runs slower than in
the 16 instead of 1300 megahertz it runs
at 1100 maximum no matter if the system
is running cool and quiet you have
plenty of battery life that is a cap
that apple limited for the 14 inch and
sometimes if you're running this under
load with some cpu tests as well it can
run as low as about 950
where the 16 inch will still run at the
full 1300 megahertz for the graphics
card speed
now what i did is i added in
the 14 inch 32 core i tested this myself
with this model right here
and that one scores 272
fps so we're going instead of going from
242 to 310 which it actually should be
320 fps if we had proper scaling we're
only going from 242 on the 24 core to
272 on the 32 so that performance isn't
that much greater for the extra cost and
having the same jump of cores as from a
16 to 24. so already we are seeing that
the 24 core is outperforming compared to
the 32 core in this 14-inch chassis and
just wait till you guys see the battery
life differences now i went ahead and
looked at the t-rex off-screen test
which luke also did but instead of him
using his 16-inch for the 32 core which
gives it a not fair advantage in this
case
i tested my 14 inch model and this test
right here it's 1080p so it's a lot more
strained on the cpu as well
and when we compare the 24 core in a 14
inch and the 32
look at that the difference is very very
little now jumping into 3dmark's
wildlife extreme this is also an
off-screen test we once again see that
kind of a difference jumping from a 16
chord to a 24 we have a nice boost and
then looking at the results that were
posted online going from the 24 to the
32 also gives you a really nice boost
but that was a 16 inch model when you
look at the 14 inch the performance is
quite a bit lower now we have to go
ahead and jump into create a text video
and the first thing he looked at is tomb
raider we had 43 fps and then jumping to
the 24 core so we have eight additional
cores we had a really nice scaling of 26
fps higher
but
if you jumped up to the 32 core instead
of gaining another 26 fps we only gained
15.
now if you find info which i looked up
info for the 16 inch with the 32 that
actually jumps 27 fps so basically a
nice linear jump in gaming performance
but once again with the 14 inch model
the 32 does not scale very well now this
is where it gets even more interesting
we've done a lot of 3d testing with
party tug for 3d rendering the 16 core
m1 pro took 9.87 seconds just under 10
which is really fast and the 24 core
scaled nicely to 6.49
we have eight extra cores and then i
added in my 32 core 14 inch that i
tested and that took 6.02
so we literally are saving less than
half a second here
jumping up to the 32 core now we're
going to go ahead and jump into video
editing which with davinci resolve which
is very very well optimized and created
tech he tested out this 8k project it's
just sample footage from red's website
and he exported this to 4k h.264
now the 16 core m1 took 60 seconds it
was really quick this is also partially
limited to the cpu performance but it
maxes out the graphics as well
because that uses it to debayer it and
to d mosaic the red footage and jumping
up to 24 core m1 max that brought it
down to 47 seconds
and with the 32 core model you would
think all right that's a good
improvement maybe we'll get another i
don't know 13 second increase but
testing it with my system it only
dropped down to 45 seconds it's only a
two second difference in export times
for all those extra cores another other
a-cores being added
now of course that has a lot of
different other limitations right we're
rendering we have encoders which we'll
talk about uh you have the graphics
performance some cpu but another test
out he did was stabilizing a two-minute
10-bit clip i went ahead and i shot on
clip that matched his settings exactly
with the same camera everything was
identical and his 16 core took 60
seconds the 24 core took 43 seconds so a
nice jump in speed and my 32 core with
the same exact settings and clip length
took 40 seconds once again barely any
improvement now another improvement if
you say that's not enough of improvement
well with the m1 max chips including the
24 core you have double the encoders
compared to the m1 pro and that can make
a significant difference for example if
you're exporting h.264 footage which we
do all the time you can do the same
thing in a minute and 52 and if you're
working with h.265 footage instead of
taking two minutes and 25 seconds for
the m1 or the 16 core m1 pro well you
could do it in a minute and 22 that is
almost twice as fast if you spend that
extra money which is 200 bucks if you're
already getting 32 gigs of ram well you
can also support four external displays
with your system instead of two and you
have 400 gigabyte per second
bandwidth instead of 200 so double the
memory bandwidth as well which does help
in things that are very memory intensive
so it's starting to make the 24 core
look like a steal of a deal if you want
32 gigs of ram now he also tested a 6
minute export using that 10 bit 422
tough footage and here uh both the 14
core and the 16 core well those take 3
minutes and 10 seconds whereas the 24
and the 32 take a minute and 41 the same
exact speed and now let's talk about the
battery life created tech what he saw
comparing a 16 core to the 24 is after a
couple hours of heavy benchmarking the
16 core had 49 remaining compared to 43
on the 24 core so you're getting a lot
more performance and extra capabilities
not with not that much difference in
battery life now luke miyani tested
three 14 inch machines going from the 14
core model to the 16 core was only a
difference of about 3
from 75 to 72 jumping to the 24 core it
dropped all the way down to 64
so that's an 8
difference compared to 16 which you're
getting quite a bit more performance and
that seemed like a big drop off when
you're looking at those numbers but when
i tested my 32 core it dropped from 100
all the way down to 52
um running the same exact test meaning
instead of dropping 8
now we dropped 12
compared to the 24 core and 20
compared to the 16. so when you look at
it this way the 32 core model doesn't
get that much better performance than
the 24 core but with that you are taking
a pretty big hit and battery life and
now going back to the original question
and issue with our 24 core model can you
even get your hands on it it does seem
like the best option especially for the
14-inch well where are they why are
there barely any information and
benchmarks and tests posted online why
have we still not got ours why do 32
core options come quicker than expected
whereas these 24s don't seem like they
are well the only thing that i can think
of is that apple is just having really
good results with 32 core options these
24 core chips they are made when you
have an issue with an m1 max chip and
one of the graphic scores are out and
they can't sell you a 32 core then they
will lock up the remaining ones and give
you a 24 core so what if apple is just
prioritizing selling the m1 max 32 core
options because they are having really
good results and yields with their m1
max chips and there are just not enough
24 cores and they rather make that extra
200 bucks that's the only thing that i
can really think of but you guys let me
know your opinions down below and is it
still worth paying another 200 bucks to
get a little bit more performance and
less battery life for you or would you
go for a 24 core if you can get one and
let me know if we should still try to
get our hands on one and do more testing
if you guys are interested in that go
ahead and click that circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there check out our
merch down below as well we would
greatly appreciate it this has been max
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]